in classical ideas about how the memory
records memories of events for example
there's the idea that the brain
processes a sequence of signals and the
signals come from the perceptual regions
of the brain and they sort of go in one
direction to higher and higher order
regions of the brain like for example
the anterior temporal lobe or the
anterior frontal lobe and it is there at
that point that the both the most
complex perceptions of complex events as
well as the most complex memories of
complex events are formed so the idea is
that if you are listening to somebody
singing or talking and at the same time
seeing the person and sort of feeling
yourself sitting in a chair because you
are in a concert hall that those
separate impressions are only going to
come together in very high order regions
of the brain and that's where they they
are going to be perceived so that's
where you have your sort of film
experience with soundtrack and whatnot
and that's also where the recording is
going to be made and there a lot of
reasons why this cannot work this way
and about 20 years ago we were dealing
with this problem and then we proposed
the framework in which we said well
first of all we now are beginning to
know that everything that moves forward
in terms of signaling in the brain does
not move just in a forward direction but
as it moves forward there's also a
feedback loop that comes to the origin
of the feed-forward
so basically we're dealing with loops
that advance but also can come back on
their tracks to the original point there
was something there was begin
to be known in that was very interesting
because it opened up possibilities about
the circuitry so this is not just in one
direction but in multiple directions
that include both the forward and the
backward and the other thing is that
there was clear evidence that when you
lose as a result of damage to the brain
when you lose regions of the brain that
are very high up like an anterior
temporal lobe or interior frontal lobe
lo and behold you don't lose the
possibility of having a complex
perception of the world in other words
your filmic experience still remains nor
do you lose the possibility of
remembering a complex perception in fact
the only thing you lose is the
possibility of dating and recognizing
the uniqueness of the perception so that
discrepancy led us to propose this idea
that there was a system of convergence
that went over multiple hierarchies
towards certain anchor points in the
brain in that what the convergence was
achieving with leading signals to a
certain point the convergence divergence
zone and what was being recorded there
was not all that was happening in your
filmmaking experience but rather the
fact that something had happened back
here that had happened simultaneously in
this region in this region in this
region and then by dint of the feedback
the the the the the backward projection
we would have the possibility later on
of reactivating the entire experience
now what this is she and that's that the
notion of convergence divergence so I
actually at first I only called it
convergence and I remember Francis Crick
telling me don't call it just
convergence that's what people are going
to remember they will never think about
the divergence part and then I later
corrected this because it was quite
right
and so the idea is that when you are
asked to remember a certain experience
that you have today in which you're
talking with person a listening to the
person's voice but you also are in a
certain context B which is the context
of a certain room in a certain building
you're going to have the separate
recordings of the of the voice of the
person the sight of the person the place
but those recordings are going to be
reactivated only if another recording of
the simultaneity of the event has been
made in a convergence diversions so and
so you you send signals forward through
convergence and then divergence will
allow for what I call the process of
retro activation in the retro activation
is going to take place in different
sites at the same time approximately or
in rapid sequence at those different
places like for example when we when we
replay music in our minds and so what
this does just to finalize the story is
create a solve a great problem of
economy in other words in instead of
having to record every event that you're
going through in your life every day
with every kind of person with the books
you read the things you see and hear in
touch and smell what you need to do is
record conjunctions of the occurrence of
certain events and then out of the
conjunction you can replay you can
reconstruct and so memory in this
perspective is always reconstructive you
are always trying to get at some
approximation of what went on rather
than an exact recording of what went on
and that's where the big difference
between the the recording in terms of
the photograph or in terms of celluloid
the picture comes we are not like that
we don't have these they are all of this
celluloid or polaroid pictures filed in
some place and we don't just replay them
in a screening room we have something
that is both far far more complex but at
the same time far more economic and that
also to certain extent because of its
fragmented nature far more prone to
error all of these things come into the
picture